MICHALE FEE: OK, so we're going
to start a new topic today.
We're going to
spend the next three
or so lectures talking
about spectral analysis.
And we're going to
warm up to that topic
today by talking about
time series more generally.
Now, one of the
things that we're
going to discuss in the
context of this new topic--
so I'm going to spend
a few minutes reviewing
a little bit about
receptive fields
that we've talked about
in the last lecture.
And one of the
really cool things
that I find in developing
tools for analyzing data
is that there's a really
big sense in which, when
we developed tools
to analyze data,
we're actually developing
tools that kind of look
like what the brain does.
So our brains basically learn
to analyze sensory stimuli
and extract information
from those sensory stimuli.
And so when we think
about developing tools
for analyzing data, we
take a lot of inspiration
from how neurons and
brain circuits actually
do the same thing.
And a lot of the
sort of formulation
that we've developed for
understanding how neurons
respond to sensory
inputs has a lot
of similarity to the kind of
things we do to analyze data.
All right, so a brief review
of mathematical models
of receptive fields--
so the basic,
most common model for thinking
about how neurons respond
to sensory stimuli is the
linear/non-linear model.
And again, the basic
idea is that we
have a sensory stimulus.
In this case, this is the
intensity of a visual field.
So it's intensity as a
function of position x and y--
let's say on the
screen or on a retina.
Then that stimulus
goes through a filter.
And the filter is
basically a pattern
of sensitivity of the
neuron to the sensory input.
And so in this case, I've
represented this filter
as a filter that's
sensitive to a ring of light
around a center of darkness.
So this might be like an
off neuron in the retina.
So that filter acts
on the stimulus.
It filters some aspect
of the stimulus,
and develops a response
to the stimulus.
That response goes to what's
called an output non-linearity,
which typically looks
something like this, where
a very negative
response produces
no spiking of the neuron,
no output of the neuron,
whereas a large overlap of
the stimulus with the filter,
with the receptive field,
produces a large spiking
response.
So a typical way this
would look for a neuron
is that if the filter
response, L, is 0,
the neuron might have some
spontaneous firing rate, r0.
And the firing
rate of the neuron
is modulated linearly around
that spontaneous firing rate r
by an amount proportional to
the response of the filter.
And then obviously if the
response of the filter
is very negative,
then the firing rate
of the neuron at
some point reaches 0.
And if the r0 plus
L goes below 0,
then the firing
rate of the neuron
can obviously not go negative.
And so the firing
rate of the neuron
will just kind of sit at
that floor of 0 firing rate.
All right, so that
is a response-- that
is an output non-linearity.
And then most neurons fire
sort of randomly, at a rate
corresponding to
this firing rate
that is the output of
this output nonlinearity.
And so what happens is a
neuron generates spikes
probabilistically at
a rate corresponding
to the output of this
non-linear response function.
OK, any questions about that?
All right, so what
we're going to do today
is I'm going to take a
little bit of a detour
and talk about how we
think about the randomness
or the stochasticity of
neuronal firing rates.
OK, and I'll talk about
the Poisson process.
And then we're going
to come back and think
about filters more
generally, and how
we can analyze signals
by applying filters
of different types to them.
OK, so I think this is basically
what we covered last time.
Again, the idea is
that we can think
of the response of a neuron
as a spontaneous firing
rate plus a filter acting
on a stimulus input.
In this case, the filter is
a two-dimensional filter.
So here I'm just fleshing out
what this looks like here,
for the case of a linear
filter in the visual system,
a spatial receptive field.
So G is the spatial
receptive field.
i is the intensity as
a function of position.
And what we do is we multiply
that spatial receptive field
times the stimulus,
and integrate over all
the spatial dimensions x and y.
In one dimension, we would
have a spatial receptive field
that looks like this.
So this receptive
field is sensitive
to a positive brightness
in the center,
and a negative or a dark
feature in the surrounding area.
And again, the way
we think about this
is that the neuron is
maximally responsive
if the pattern of sensory
input looks like the receptive
field, is highly correlated
with the receptive field.
So if the receptive field
has a positive central region
surrounded by negative
flanks, then that neuron
is maximally responsive
if the pattern of light
looks like the receptive field.
So if the light pattern has
a bright spot surrounded
by dark flanking
regions, then we
calculate this
integral, what you find
is that the positive parts--
the positive receptive field
times the positive intensity
or brightness multiplies to
give you a positive contribution
to the neuronal response.
A negative component
of the receptive field
multiplies by a negative
component of the intensity.
And that gives you a positive
contribution to the response.
And so you can see that even
though the receptive field has
positive and negative
parts, so does
the intensity function have
positive and negative parts.
And when you multiply
those together,
you get a positive contribution
to the response of the neuron
everywhere.
And so when you integrate
that, you get a big response.
In contrast, if the intensity
profile looked like this--
it's very broad.
So this looks like a bright
spot surrounded by a dark ring.
If, on the other hand, you
have a large bright spot that
completely overlaps
this receptive field,
then when you multiply these
two functions together,
this positive times positive
will give you a positive here.
But the negative part
of the receptive field
overlaps with a positive
part of the intensity.
And that gives you a
negative contribution
to the neuronal response.
And when you integrate
that, the positive here
is canceled by the
negative there,
and you get a small response.
All right, any
questions about that?
I think we covered that in
a lot of detail last time.
But again, the
important point here
is that this neuron is
looking for a particular kind
of pattern in the sensory input.
And it responds when the
sensory input has that pattern.
It doesn't respond as well
when the sensory input has
a different pattern.
And we have the same
kind of situation
for the sensitivity of
neurons to temporal patterns.
So we can write down the
firing rate of a neuron
as a function of time.
It's just a spontaneous firing
rate plus a filter acting
on a time-dependent stimulus.
So in this case, this
filter will be looking for
or sensitive to a
particular temporal pattern.
And as you recall, if we have
a time-dependent stimulus--
let's say this is the
intensity of a spot of light,
that you can have
a neuron that's
responsive to a particular
temporal pattern.
Let's say a brief darkening
of the stimulus followed
by a pulse of bright
high intensity,
and then the neuron
response after it sees
that pattern in the stimulus.
And the way we think
about this mathematically
is that what's happening
is that the stimulus
is being convolved with
this linear temporal kernel.
And the way we think about
that is that the kernel
is sliding across the stimulus.
We're doing that
same kind of overlap.
We're multiplying the
stimulus times the kernel,
integrating over
time, and asking,
where in time does the
stimulus have a strong overlap
with the kernel?
And you can see
that in this case,
there's a strong
overlap at this point.
The stimulus looks
like the kernel.
The positive parts
of the stimulus
overlap with positive
parts of the kernel.
Negative parts of the stimulus
overlap with negative parts
of the kernel.
So when you multiply
that all together,
you get a big positive response.
And if you actually slide that
across and do that integral
as a function of time, you can
see that this convolution has
a peak at the point where
that kernel overlaps
with the stimulus.
And right there is
where the neuron
would tend to produce a spike.
All right, and so, I think near
the end of the last lecture,
we talked about integrating
or putting together
the spatial and temporal
parts of a receptive field
into sort of a larger concept
of a spatio-temporal receptive
field that combines both spatial
and temporal information.
All right, so here
are the things
that we're going to
talk about today.
We're going to again, take
a little bit of a detour,
and talk about spike
trains being probabilistic.
We'll talk about a
Poisson process, which
is the kind of random process
that most people think
about when you talk about
spike trains of neurons.
We're going to develop a couple
of measures of spike train
variability.
So an important thing
that neuroscientists often
think about when you
measure spike trains
is how variable are they,
how reproducible are they
in responding to a stimulus.
And a number of different
statistical measures
have been developed to
quantify spike trains.
And we're just going to
describe those briefly.
And I think you'll
have a problem set
problem that deals with those.
And then I'm going to come
back to kind of a broader
discussion of convolution.
I'll introduce two
new metrics or methods
for analyzing time series data,
data that's a function of time.
Those are cross-correlation
and autocorrelation functions.
And I'm going to relate
those to the convolution
that you've been
using more often
and we've been seeing in class.
And then finally we're
going to jump right
into spectral analysis
of time series, which
is a way of pulling out
periodic signals from data.
And what you're going to see is
that that method of pulling out
temporal structure
out of signals
looks a lot like the
way we've been talking
about how neurons
have sensitivity
to temporal
structure in signals.
OK, we're going to use that
same idea of taking a signal
and asking how much
does it overlap
with a linear kernel
with a filter.
And we're going to talk
about the kind of filters
you use to detect periodic
structure and signal.
And not surprisingly, those are
going to be periodic filters.
All right so that's what we're
going to talk about today.
All right, so let's start with
probabilistic spike trains.
So the first thing
that you discover
when you record from
neurons in the brain
and you present a
stimulus to the animal--
let's say you record from
neurons in visual cortex
or auditory cortex,
and you present
a stimulus for some period
of time, what you find
is that the neurons respond.
They respond with some
temporal structure.
But each time you
present the stimulus,
the response of the neuron
is a little bit different.
So you can see that this--
so what I'm showing here
is a raster plot.
So each row of this shows
the spiking activity
of a neuron during a
presentation of this stimulus.
The stimulus is a bunch of
dots presented that move
across the screen.
And this is a part of the brain
that sensitive to movement
of visual stimuli.
And what you can see is
that each time the stimulus
is presented, the
neuron generates spikes.
Each row here is a different
presentation of the stimulus.
If you average across
all of those rows,
you can see that there is
some repeatable structure.
So the neuron tends to spike
most often at certain times
after the presentation
of this stimulus.
But each time the
stimulus is presented,
the spikes don't occur in
exactly the same place.
So you have this sense that
when you present the stimulus,
there is some sort of underlying
modulation of the firing
rate of the neuron.
But the response isn't
exactly the same each time.
There's some
randomness about it.
So we're going to talk a little
bit about how you characterize
that randomness.
And the way that most people
think about the random spiking
of neurons is that there is a--
sorry about that.
That mu was supposed
to be up there.
So let's go to a very
simple case, where
we turn on a stimulus.
And instead of having a
kind of a time-varying rate,
let's imagine that the
stimulus just comes on,
and the neuron starts to spike
at a constant average rate.
And let's call that
average rate mu.
So what does that mean?
What that means is
that if you were
to present this stimulus
many, many times
and look at where
the spikes occur,
there would be some uniform
probability per unit of time
that spikes would occur
anywhere under that stimulus
during the presentation
of that stimulus.
So let's break
that time window up
during the presentation
of the stimulus
into little tiny
bins, delta-T. Now,
if these spikes occur
randomly, then they're
generated independently
of any other spikes,
with an equal
probability in each bin.
And what that means is that
if the bins are small enough,
most of the bins will
have zero spikes.
And you can write
down the probability
that a spike occurs in any one
bin is the number of spikes
per unit time, which is
the average firing rate,
times the width of
that bin in time.
Does that make sense?
The probability that you have a
spike in any one of those very
tiny bins is just going to be
the spikes per unit of time
times the width of
the bin in time.
Now, that's only true if
delta-T is very small.
Because if delta-T
gets big, then you
have some probability that you
could have two or three spikes.
And so this is only
true in the case
where delta-t is very small.
So the probability
that no spikes
occur is 1 minus mu
delta-T. And we can ask,
how many spikes land
in this interval T?
And we're going to call
that probability P. And it's
the probability that n spikes
land in this interval, T.
And we can calculate that
probability as follows.
So that probability
is just the product
of three different things.
It's the probability of
having n bins with a spike.
So that's mu delta-T to the n.
It's n independent events,
with probability mu delta-T,
times the probability of having
M minus n beans with no spike.
So that's 1 minus mu
delta-T to the M minus n.
And we also have to multiply
by the number of different ways
that you can distribute
those n spikes in M bins.
And that's called M choose n.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So when
we pick delta-T,
we still have to
pick it big enough so
that it's not less than how
long the [INAUDIBLE],, right?
Because you can't have--
MICHALE FEE: Yeah,
so, OK, good question.
So just to clarify, we're
kind of imagining that spikes
are delta functions now.
So we are-- so in
this case, we're
imagining that spikes
are not like produced
by influx of sodium and
an outflux of potassium,
and it takes a millisecond.
In general, spikes are, let's
say, a millisecond across.
And we're usually
thinking of these bins
as kind of approaching
about a millisecond.
But if you-- what
we're about to do,
actually, is take the limit
where delta-T goes to 0.
And in that case,
you have to think
of the spikes as
delta functions.
OK, so the probability
that you have
n spikes in this
interval, T, is just
the product of those things.
It's the probability
of having n bins
with a spike times the
number of different ways
that you can put n
spikes into M bins.
So you multiply those
things together,
and you take the limit
that delta-T goes to 0.
And it's kind of a
cute little derivation.
I've put the full
derivation at the end
so that we don't have to
go through it in class.
But it's kind of fun
to look at anyway.
And what you find is that in the
limit, that delta-T goes to 0.
Of course as delta-T goes
to 0, the number of bins
goes to infinity.
Because the number of
bins is just capital
T divided by delta-T.
So you can go through
each of those terms
and calculate what happens
to them in the limit
that delta-T goes to 0.
And what you find is
that the probability
of having n spikes
in that window
T just like mu T to the n.
What is mu T?
mu T is the expected number
of spikes in that interval.
It's just the number of
spikes per unit time,
times the length of the
window divided by n factorial,
times e to the minus
mu T. And again, mu T
is the expected
number of spikes.
And that is the
Poisson distribution.
And it comes from a very
simple assumption, which
is just that spikes occur.
The spikes occur
independently of each other,
at a rate mu spikes per second,
with some constant probability
per unit time of having a
spike in each little time bin.
Now notice that if
you have a rate--
there's some tiny probability
per unit of time of having
a spike there, probability
of having a spike there,
probability of having a
spike there, and so on--
you're going to end up sometimes
with one spike in the window,
sometimes with two spikes,
sometimes with three,
sometimes four, sometimes five.
If this window's
really short, you're
going to have more cases where
you have zero or one spikes.
If this window is
really long, then it's
going to be pretty rare to
have just 0 or 1 spikes.
And you're going to end
up with, on average,
20 spikes, let's say.
So you could see that, first
of all, the number of spikes
you get is random.
And it depends on the
size of the window.
And the average number
of bikes you get
depends on the
size of the window
and the average firing
rate of the neuron.
OK, so let's just take a look
at what this function looks
like for different
expected spike counts.
So here's what that looks like.
So we can calculate the
expected number of spikes.
And just to convince you, if
we calculate the average number
of spikes using
that distribution,
we just sum, over all
possible number of spikes,
n times the probability
of having n spikes.
And when you do
that, what you find
is that the average
number is mu times T.
So you can see that the
firing rate, mu, is just
the expected number
of spikes divided
by the width of the window.
Does that make sense?
That's pretty obvious.
That's just the spike rate.
And we're going to often
use the variable r for that,
for firing rate.
OK.
And here's what that looks like.
You can see that if the
firing rate is low enough
or the window is short enough,
such that the expected number
of spikes is 1, you can
see that, most of the time,
you're going to
get 0 or 1 spikes,
and then occasionally 2,
and very occasionally 3,
and then almost never
more than 4 or 5.
If the expected
number of spikes is 4,
you can see that the
mode of that-- you
can see that that distribution
moves to the right.
You have a higher probability
of getting 3 or 4 spikes.
But again, there's
still a distribution.
So even if the average
number of spikes is 4,
you have quite a wide range
of actual spike counts
that you would get
on any given trial.
As the expected number of
spikes gets bigger-- let's say,
on average, 10--
does anyone know what
this distribution
starts turning into?
AUDIENCE: Gaussian.
MICHALE FEE: Gaussian, good.
So what you can see
is that you end up
having a more symmetric
distribution, where the peak is
sitting at the expected number.
In that case, the distribution
becomes more symmetric,
and in the limit of infinite
expected number of spikes,
becomes exactly a
Gaussian distribution.
All right, there
are two measures
that we use to characterize
how variable spike trains are.
Le me just go through
them real quick.
And we'll describe--
and I'll describe to you
what we expect those to look
like for spike trains that
have a Poisson distribution.
So the first thing
we can look at
is the variance in
the spike count.
So remember, for
a Poisson process,
the average number of
spikes in the interval
is mu times T. We can calculate
the variance in that, which
is basically just some
measure of the width
of this distribution here.
So the variance
is just the number
of counts on a given trial minus
the expected number, squared.
n minus average and, squared.
And if you multiply
that out, you get--
it's the average n squared
minus the average squared.
And it turns out, for
the Poisson process,
that that variance is also
mu T. So the variance is--
the average spike count
is mu T, and the variance
in the spike count is also mu T.
So there is a quantity called
the Fano factor, which is just
defined as the variance
of the spike count divided
by the average spike count.
And for a Poisson process,
the Fano factor is 1.
And what you find is that
for neurons in cortex
and other parts of the brain,
the Fano factor actually
can be quite close to one.
It's usually between
1 and 1 and 1/2 or so.
So there's been a lot of
discussion and interest
in why it is that spike
counts in the brain
are actually so random, why do
neurons behave in such a way
that their spikes occur
essentially randomly
at some rate.
So it's a interesting topic
of current research interest.
OK, let me tell you about
one other measure, called
the interspike
interval distribution.
And basically the inner
spike interval distribution
is the distribution of
times between spikes.
And I'm just going
to show you what
that looks like in
the Poisson process,
and then briefly
describe what that
looks like for real neurons.
OK, so let's say
we have a spike.
OK, let's calculate
the distribution
of intervals between spikes.
So let's say we have a
spike at time T-sub-i.
We're going to ask what is
the probability that we have
a spike some time, tau, later--
tau-sub-i later, within
some little window, delta-T.
So let's calculate that.
So tau-sub-i is
initial spike interval
between the i-plus-1
spike and the i-th spike.
So the probability of
having the next spike
land in the interval between
t of i plus 1 and t of i
plus 1 plus delta t in
this little window here
is going to be what?
It's going to be the
probability of having
no spike in this interval,
times the probability of having
a spike in that little interval.
So what's the
probability of having
no spike in that interval, tau?
What distribution can we use
to calculate that probability?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
So what is the
Poisson distribution?
It tells us the
probability of having
n spikes in an
interval T-- capital T.
So how would we use
that to calculate
the probability of having
no spike in that interval?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MICHALE FEE: Exactly.
We just use the
Poisson distribution,
and plug n equals 0 into it.
So go to that.
There's the Poisson
distribution.
What does this look like
if we set n equals 0?
So what is mu T to the zero?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: 1.
What is 0 factorial?
AUDIENCE: 1.
MICHALE FEE: 1.
And so the probability of
having zero spikes in a window T
is just e to the minus mu T. All
right, so let's plug that in--
good.
So the probability of having
no spikes in that interval
is e to the minus mu T, or rT,
if we're using r for rate now.
Now, what is the
probability of having
a spike in that little
window right there?
Any thoughts?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: What's that?
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
You could do that.
But we sort of derive
the Poisson process
by using the answer to
this question already.
AUDIENCE: Oh, r delta.
MICHALE FEE: r delta-T. Good.
OK, so the probability of having
a spike in that little window
is just r delta-T. OK.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Stupid
question-- I just missed
the transition between u and r.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah,
I just changed
the name of the variable.
If you look in the
statistics literature,
they most often use mu.
But when we're talking about
prime rates of neurons,
it's more convenient to use R.
And so they're just the same.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are we
talking the probability
of having the next five
commands [INAUDIBLE]
given that there was no
spike at the first interval?
MICHALE FEE: Well, so
remember, the probability
of having a spike in any
interval in a process
is completely independent of
what happens at any other time.
AUDIENCE: So why
are we calculating--
why did we do that [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHALE FEE: OK, because
in order for this
to be the interval between
one spike and the next spike,
we needed to have zero spikes
in the intervening interval.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK,
so [INAUDIBLE]..
OK.
MICHALE FEE:
Because if there had
been another spike
in here somewhere,
this would not be our
inter-spike interval.
The inter-spike interval would
be between here and wherever
that spike occurred.
And we'd just be
back to calculating
what's the probability of
having no spike between there
and there.
OK, good.
So that's the probability
of having no spike from here
to here, and having a spike
in the next little delta-T.
We can now calculate what's
called the probability density.
It's the probability
per unit time
of having inter-spike
intervals of that duration.
And to do that,
we just calculate
the probability divided by
delta-T. And what you find
is that the probability density
of inter-spike intervals
is just re to the
minus r tau, where
tau is the spike interval.
And so this is what that looks
like for a Poisson process.
OK, so you can see that
the highest probability
is having very short intervals.
And you have exponentially
lower probabilities
of having longer and
longer intervals.
Does that make sense?
So it turns out
that that's actually
a lot like what interspike
intervals of real neurons
looks like.
They very often have
this exponential tail.
Now, what is
completely unrealistic
about this interspike
interval distribution?
What is it that can't
be true about this?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Intervals,
like, which are huge.
MICHALE FEE: Well,
so it's actually--
the bigger problem is not on
this end of the distribution.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
What happens here that's wrong?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Exactly.
So what happens immediately
after a neuron spikes?
AUDIENCE: You
can't have a spike.
MICHALE FEE: You can't have
another spike right away.
Why is that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Because of
the refractory period,
which comes from--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Hyperpolarization
is one of them.
Once you have the
spike, the neuron
is actually briefly
hyperpolarized.
You could imagine trying to
re-polarize it very quickly,
but then something
else is a problem.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Sodium
channel inactivation.
So even if you were to
repolarize the neuron very
quickly, it still
would have a hard time
making a spike because of
sodium channel inactivation.
So what does this actually
look like for real neuron?
What do you imagine
it looks like?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Right, so
immediately after a spike,
there is zero probability
of having another spike.
So this starts at
zero, climbs up here,
and then decays exponentially.
OK, so that's what most
inter-spike intervals
for real neurons
actually looks like.
So this is probability density.
This is tau.
And this is the
refractory period.
In fact, when you
record from neurons
with an electrode in the
brain, you get lots of spikes.
One of the first
things you should
do when you set a threshold
and find those spike times
is compute by
interval distribution.
Because if you're recording
from a single neuron,
that interspike
interval distribution
will have this
refractory period.
If you're recording
from-- it's quite easy
to get multiple spikes on
the end of an electrode.
And what happens if you
have multiple spikes,
you can think they're
coming from one neuron,
but in fact they're
coming from two neurons.
And if you compute the
interspike interval
distribution, it won't
have this dip here.
So it's a really important
tool to use to test
whether your signal is clean.
You'd be amazed at how few
people actually do that.
All right, I just
want to introduce you
to one important term.
And that's called homogeneous
versus inhomogeneous
in the context of
Poisson process.
What that means is that a
homogeneous Poisson process has
a constant rate, mu.
Most neurons don't do that.
Because in most neurons,
there's information
carried in the fluctuation
of the firing rate.
And so most neurons have
what's called behave more
like an inhomogeneous
Poisson process,
where the rate is actually
fluctuating in time.
And the example we
were looking at before
shows you what an
inhomogenous Poisson
process would look like.
So let's see what's next.
All right, so
let's change topics
to talk about convolution,
cross-correlation,
and auto-correlation functions.
All right, so we've been using
the notion of a convolution
where we have a kernel that
we multiply by a signal.
We multiply that, and
integrate over time,
and then we slide that
kernel across the signal,
and ask, where does the
signal have structure
that looks like the kernel.
And that gives you
an output y of T.
So we've used that to model
the membrane potential
of [INAUDIBLE] synaptic input.
So in that case, we
had spikes coming
from a presynaptic neuron
that generate a response
in the postsynaptic neuron.
And now we can take--
the output of that, the response
in the postsynaptic neuron
as a convolution of
that exponential,
with an input spike train.
We've used it to model
the response of neurons
to a time-dependent stimulus.
And you also used it--
I've described how you
can use that to implement
a low-pass filter or
a high-pass filter.
And we talked about
doing that for extracting
either low-frequency signals,
to get the local field
potential out of neurons, or
doing a high-pass filter to get
rid of the low-frequency signals
so that you can see the spikes.
OK, but most generally,
convolution is--
you should think
about it as allowing
you to model how a system
responds to an input
where the response
of the system is
controlled by a linear filter.
The system is sensitive
to particular patterns
in the input.
Those patterns can be
detected by a filter.
So you apply that
filter to the input,
and you estimate how
the system responds.
And it's very broadly useful
in engineering and biology
and neuroscience to use
convolutions to model
how a system responds
to its input.
All right, so there is a
different kind of function,
called a cross-correlation
function, that looks like this.
And it looks very
similar to a convolution,
but it's used very differently.
Now, you might think, OK,
there's just a sign change.
Here I have a T minus tau,
and here I have a T plus tau.
Is that the only
difference between those?
It's not.
Because here I'm
integrating over a d tau,
and here I'm
integrating over dT.
Here I'm getting the response
as a function of time.
Here, what I'm doing is I'm
kind of extracting the kernel.
What I'm getting out of
this is a kernel, tau,
as a function of tau.
OK, so let me walk
through how that works.
So in this case, we have
two signals, x and y.
And what we're doing is we're
taking those two signals
and we're multiplying them
by each other, x times y.
And what we're doing is
we're multiplying the signals
and then integrating
over the product.
And then we shift
one of those signals
by a little amount, tau.
And we repeat that process.
So let's see what
that looks like.
So what do you see here?
You see two different
signals, x and [AUDIO OUT]
I'm sorry, x and y.
They look kind of similar.
You can see this
one has a bump here,
and a couple bumps
there, and a bump there.
And you see something pretty
similar to that here, right?
Here's three big bumps.
So those signals are actually
quite similar to each other,
but they're not
exactly the same.
Right you can see that these
fast little fluctuations are
different on those two signals.
Now, what happens when
we take this signal--
and you can see that
there's this offset here.
So what happens if
we take x times y,
we multiply them together,
and we integrate the result?
Then we shift y a little
bit, by an amount, tau,
and we multiply those
two signals together,
and we integrate.
And we keep doing that.
And now we're going
to plot this k
as a function of that
little shift, tau,
that we put in there.
And here's what that looks like.
So k is the cross-correlation--
sometimes called the lag
cross-correlation-- of x and y.
So that little
circle is the symbol
for lag cross-correlation.
And you can see that,
at a particular lag,
like right here, the positive
fluctuations in this signal
are going to line up with
the positive fluctuations
in that signal.
The negative fluctuations
in this signal
are going to line up with
the negative fluctuations
in that signal.
And when you multiply
them together,
you're going to get the
maximum positive contribution.
Those signals are going
to be maximally overlapped
at a particular shift, tau.
And when you put that
function, K of tau,
you're going to have a
peak at that lag that
corresponds to where those
signals are maximally
overlapped.
So a lag cross-correlation
function is really useful
for finding, let's say, the
time at which two signals--
like if one signal is like
a copy of the other one,
but it's shifted in time, a
lag cross-correlation function
is really useful for finding
that the lag between those two
functions.
There's another context in
which this lag cross-correlation
function is really useful.
So when we did the
spike-triggered average,
when we took spikes
from a neuron, and we--
at the time of those
spikes, we extracted
what the input
was to the neuron,
and we averaged
that [AUDIO OUT]..
What we were really doing was we
were doing a cross-correlation
between the spike train of
a neuron and the stimulus
that drove that neuron,
the stimulus that
was input to that neuron.
And that
cross-correlation was just
the kernel that
described how you
get from that
input to the neuron
to the response of the neuron.
So spike-triggered average
is actually sometimes called
reverse correlation.
And the reverse
comes from the fact
that you have to actually flip
this over to get the kernel.
So let's not worry about that.
But it's sometimes referred
to as the correlation
between the spike train
and the stimulus input.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: So there's
no convolution here.
We're doing the lag
cross-correlation, OK.
We're just taking
those two signals,
and shifting one of them,
multiplying, and integrating.
Sorry.
Ask your question.
I just wanted to
clarify, there's
no convolution being done here.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
is that y [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Ah, OK, great.
That's actually one
of the things that's
easiest to get
mixed up about when
you do lag cross-correlation.
You have to be careful about
which side this peak is on.
And I personally can
never keep it straight.
So what I do is just
make two test functions,
and stick them in.
And make sure that if I
have one of my functions--
so in this case, here
are two test functions.
You can see that x is--
sorry, y is before x.
And so this peak
here corresponds
to y happening before x.
So you just have to make sure
you know what the sign is.
And I recommend doing that
with just two functions
that you know.
It's easy to get it backwards.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] part
of y equals [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: What do
you mean, first part?
AUDIENCE: The very
first [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: Oh, these?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MICHALE FEE: I'm just
taking copies of this,
and placing them on top of
each other, and shifting them.
So you should ignore this
little part right here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Oh, yeah.
So there are Matlab functions
to do this cross-correlation.
And it handles all of
that stuff for you.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Like,
is the x-axis tau?
MICHALE FEE: The x-axis is tau.
I should have
labeled it on there.
AUDIENCE: I just want to
clarify whether they meet.
So how it's kind of flat, and
then this idea of the flat area
that, when you multiply them
and they're slightly off,
this is generally not zero.
But you know, they
cancel each other out.
MICHALE FEE: So you can see that
if these things are shifted--
if they're kind of noisy, and
they're shifted with respect
to each other, you can see
that the positive parts here
might line up with the
negative parts there.
And the negative parts here
line up with the positive parts
there.
And they're shifted randomly
at any other time with respect
to each other.
On average, positive
times negative,
you're going to have
some parts where
it's positive times positive,
and other parts where
it's positive times negative.
And it's all going to wash
out and give you zero.
Because those signals are
uncorrelated with each other
at different time lags.
AUDIENCE: So only when the
perfectly overlap and kind
of exaggerate each other
is when they'll be flat.
MICHALE FEE: Exactly.
It's only when they overlap
that all of the positive parts
here will line up with
the positive parts here,
and the negative parts
here will line up
with the negative parts.
AUDIENCE: And since you're
taking the integral together,
it just makes a
very large positive.
MICHALE FEE: Exactly.
All of those positive
times positive
add up to the negative times
negative, which is positive.
And all of that
adds up to give you
that positive peak right there.
But when they're shifted, all
of those magical alignments
of positive with positive and
negative with negative go away.
And it just becomes, on
average, just random.
And random things have zero
correlation with each other.
So this is actually
a really powerful way
to discover the relation
between two different signals.
And in fact, it
gives you a kernel
that you can actually
use to predict
one signal from another signal.
Now, if you were to take
x and convolve it with k,
you would get an estimate of y.
We'll talk more
about that later.
Pretty cool, right?
So they're mathematically
very similar.
They look similar.
But they're used
in different ways.
So the way we think
about convolution is--
what it's used for is to
take an input signal x,
and convolve it with a kernel,
k, to get an output signal, y.
And we usually think of x
as being very long vectors,
long signals.
K here, kappa, is a kernel.
It's just a short
little thing in time.
And you're going to convolve
it with a long signal
to get another long signal.
Does that makes sense?
In cross-correlation, we
have two signals, x and y.
x and y are the inputs.
And we cross-correlate
it to extract
a short signal that captures
the temporal relation between x
and y.
All right, so x and
y are long signals.
K is a short vector.
And in this case, we're
convolving a long signal
with a short kernel to get
another long signal, which
is the response of the system.
In this case, we take,
let's say, the input
to a system and the
output of this system,
and doing a cross-correlation
to extract the kernel.
All right, any
questions about that?
They're both
super-powerful methods.
Yes, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: How does the
cross-correlation--
mathematically, how does it
give a short vector [INAUDIBLE]??
MICHALE FEE: You just do this
for a small number of taus.
Because usually
signals that have
some relation between
them, that relation
has a short time extent.
This signal here, in a
real physical system,
doesn't depend on what x was
doing a month ago, or maybe
a few seconds ago.
These signals might be 10 or 20
seconds long, or an hour long,
but this signal, y,
doesn't depend on what
x was doing an hour ago.
It only depends on
what x was doing
maybe a few tens of
milliseconds or a second ago.
So that's why x and y
can be long signals.
K is a short vector that
represents the kernel.
Any more questions about that?
OK, these are very
powerful methods.
We use them all the time.
I talked about the relation to
the spike-triggered average.
The autocorrelation is nothing
more than a cross-correlation
of a signal with itself.
So let's see how that's useful.
So an autocorrelation
is a good way
to examine a temporal
structure within a signal.
So if we take a signal,
x, and we calculate
the cross-correlation of
that signal with itself,
here's what that looks like.
So let's say we have a
signal that looks like this.
And this signal kind of
has slowish fluctuations
that are, let's say, on a 50
or 100 millisecond timescale.
If we take that signal and
we multiply it by itself
with zero time lag, what do
you think that will look like?
So positive lines up with
positive, negative lines
up with negative.
That thing should do what?
It should be a maximum, right?
Autocorrelations are always
a maximum at zero lag.
And then what we do is we're
just going to take that signal
and shift it a little bit.
And we'll shift it
a little bit more,
do that product and
integral, shift that product
and integral.
Now what's going to happen as
we shift one of those signals
sideways?
And then multiply and integrate.
Sammy, you got this one.
AUDIENCE: Oh, at first,
[INAUDIBLE] zero [INAUDIBLE]
point where the plus
and minuses cancel out.
[INAUDIBLE] this.
If you [INAUDIBLE]
maybe [INAUDIBLE]
where the pluses
overlap the second time.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, so
if you shift it enough,
it's possible that it might
overlap again somewhere else.
What kind of signal
would that happen for?
AUDIENCE: Like, cyclical.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah,
a periodic signal.
Exactly.
So an autocorrelation first
of all has a peak at zero lag.
That peak drops off when
these fluctuations here.
So the positive lines up
with positive, negative lines
up with negative.
As you shift one of them,
those positive and negatives
no longer overlap
with each other,
and you start getting positives
lining up with negatives.
And so the
autocorrelation drops off.
And then it can actually
go back and indicate--
it can go back up if
there's periodic structure.
So let's look at what
this one looks like.
So in this case,
it kind of looked
like there might be
periodic structure,
but there wasn't,
because this was
just low-pass-filtered noise.
And you can see that
if you compute the--
there's that Matlab
function, xcorr.
So you use it to calculate
the autocorrelation.
You can see that that
autocorrelation is peaked
at zero lag, drops off, and
the lag at which it drops off
depends on how smoothly
varying that function is.
If the function varies--
if it's changing very
slowly, the autocorrelation
is going to be very wide.
Because you have to
shift it a lot in order
to get the positive peaks
and the negative peaks
misaligned from each other.
Now, if you have a
fast signal like this,
with fast fluctuations, and
you do the autocorrelation,
what's going to happen?
So first of all, at zero
lag, it's going to be peak.
And then what's going to happen?
It's going to drop
off more quickly.
So that's exactly what happens.
So here's the autocorrelation
of this slow function.
Here's the autocorrelation
of this fast function.
And you can see both of
these are just noise.
But I've smoothed this one.
I've low-pass-filtered
this with kind
of a 50-millisecond-wide
kernel to give
very slowly-varying structure.
This one I smoothed with
a very narrow kernel
to leave fast fluctuations.
And you can see that the
autocorrelation shows
that the width of the smoothing
of this signal is very narrow.
And the width of the smoothing
for this signal was broad.
In fact what you can see
is that this signal looks
like noise that's been
convolved with this,
and this signal looks
like noise that's
been convolved with that.
And here is actually
a demonstration
of what Sammy was
just talking about.
If you take a look
at this signal,
so the autocorrelation can
be a very powerful method.
It's actually not that powerful.
It's a method for extracting
periodic structure.
And we're going to
turn now, very shortly,
to a method that really is
very powerful for extracting
periodic structure.
But I just want to show you
how this method can be used.
And so if you look at
that signal right there,
it looks like noise.
But there's actually
structure embedded in there
that we can see if we do the
autocorrelation of this signal.
And here's what that looks like.
So again, autocorrelation
has peaked.
The peak is very
narrow, because that's
a very noisy-looking signal.
But you can see that,
buried under there,
is this periodic fluctuation.
What that says is that if I
take a copy of that signal
and shift it with respect to
itself every 100 milliseconds,
something in there
starts lining up again.
And that's why you
have these little peaks
in the autocorrelation function.
And what do you think
that is buried in there?
The sine wave.
So this data is random,
with a normal distribution,
plus 0.1 times cosine that
gives you a 10 hertz wiggle.
So you can't see
that in the data.
But if you do the
autocorrelation,
all of a sudden you can see
that it's buried in there.
All right, so
cross-correlation is a way
to extract the temporal relation
between different signals.
Autocorrelation is a way to
use the same method essentially
to extract the temporal
relation between a signal
and itself at different times.
And that method, it's
actually quite commonly used
to extract structure
and spike trains.
But there are much
more powerful methods
for extracting
periodic structure.
And that's what we're going
to start talking about now.
OK, any questions?
Let's start on the topic
of spectral analysis, which
is the right way to pull out the
periodic structure of signals.
Here's that the spectrogram
that I was actually
trying to show you last time.
So what is a spectrogram?
So if we have a sound--
we record a sound
with a microphone,
microphones pick up
pressure fluctuations.
So in this case, this
is a bird singing.
The vocal cords are vibrating
with air flowing through them
that produce very large
pressure fluctuations
in the vocal tract.
And those are transmitted out
through the beak, into the air.
And that produces
pressure fluctuations
that propagate through
the air at about
a foot per millisecond.
They reach your ear, and
they vibrate your eardrum.
And if you have a
microphone there,
you can actually record
those pressure fluctuations.
And if you look at it, it
just looks like fast wiggles
in the pressure.
But somehow your ear is able
to magically transform that
into this neural representation
of what that sound is.
And what your ear
is actually doing
is it's doing a spectral
analysis of the sound.
And then your brain is
doing a bunch of processing
that helps you identify
what that thing is
that's making that sound.
So this is a spectral
analysis of this bit
of birdsong, canary song.
And what it is, it does very
much what your eardrum does--
or what your cochlea does.
Sorry.
It calculates how
much power there
is at different
frequencies of the sound
and at different times.
So what this says
is that there's
a lot of power in this sound
at 5 kilohertz at this time,
but at this time, there's a lot
of power at 3 kilohertz or a 2
kilohertz and so on.
So it's a graphical way of
describing what the sound is.
And here's what that looks like.
[DESCENDING WHISTLING BIRDSONG]
[FULL-THROATED CHIRP]
[RAPID CHIRPS]
[SIREN-LIKE CHIRPS]
[STUDENTS LAUGH]
So you can see visually
what's happening.
Even though if you were
to look at those patterns
on an oscilloscope or
printed out on the computer,
it would just be a
bunch of wiggles.
You wouldn't be able
to see any of that.
Here's another example.
This is a baby bird babbling.
And here's an example of
what those signals actually
look like--
just a bunch of wiggles.
It's almost completely
uninterpretable.
But again, your brain does
this spectral analysis.
And here I'm showing
a spectrogram.
Again, this is
frequency versus time.
It's much more
cluttered visually.
And it's a little bit
harder to interpret.
But your brain actually does a
pretty good job figuring out--
[RANDOM SQUEAKY CHIRPING]
--what's going on there.
We can also do spectral
analysis of neural signals.
So one of the really cool things
that happens in the cortex
is that neural circuits
produce oscillations.
And they produce oscillations
at different frequencies
at different times.
If you close your
eyes-- everybody just
close your eyes for a second.
As soon as you close your
eyes, the back of your cortex
starts generating a big
10 hertz oscillation.
It's wild.
You just close your eyes,
and it starts going--
[MAKES OSCILLATING SOUND WITH
MOUTH]
--at 10 hertz.
This is a rhythm that's
produced by the hippocampus.
So whenever you start
walking, your hippocampus
starts generating
a 10 hertz rhythm.
When you stop and you're
thinking about something
or eating something, it stops.
As soon as you start walking--
[MAKES OSCILLATING SOUND WITH
MOUTH]
--10 hertz rhythm.
And you can see that rhythm
often in neural signals.
Here you can see
this 10 Hertz rhythm.
It has a period of
about 100 milliseconds.
But on top of that, there
are much faster rhythms.
It's not always so obvious in
the brain what the rhythms are.
And you need spectral analysis
techniques to help pull out
that structure.
You can see here,
here is the frequency
as a function of time.
I haven't labeled the axis here.
But this bright band right here
corresponds to this 10 hertz
oscillation.
So we're going to take up a
little bit of a detour into how
to actually carry out
state-of-the-art spectral
analysis like this to allow
you to detect very subtle,
small signals in neural
signals, or sound signals,
or any kind of signal that
you're interested in studying.
Jasmine.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, OK, so
this is called a color map.
I didn't put that
on the side here.
But basically dark
here means no power.
And light blue to
green is more power.
Yellow to red is even more.
Same here.
So red is most power.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yes.
So it's how much energy there
is at different frequencies
in the signal as a
function of time.
So you're going to
know how to do this.
Don't worry.
you're going to be world
experts at how to do this right.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: This is very
similar to [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: Yes.
I'm sorry.
I should have been
clear-- this is
recording from an electrode
in the hippocampus.
And these oscillations here
are the local field potentials.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yes.
That's exactly right.
Thank you.
I should have been
more clear about that.
OK, all right, so in
order to understand
how to really do this,
you have to understand
Fourier decomposition.
And once you understand that,
the rest is pretty easy.
So I'm going to take
you very slowly--
and it may feel a little
grueling at first.
But if you understand
this, the rest is simple.
So let's just get started.
All right, so Fourier series--
it's a way of decomposing
periodic signals
by applying filters to them.
We're going to take a signal
that's a function of time,
and we're going to make
different receptive fields.
We're going to make
neurons that have--
sensitive to
different frequencies.
And we're going to apply those
different filters to extract
what different frequencies
there are in that signal.
So we're going to take
this periodic signal
as a function of time.
It's a square wave.
It has a period capital T.
And what we're going to do
is we're going to
approximate that square wave
as a sum of a bunch of
different sine waves.
So the first thing we can do
is approximate it as a cosine.
You can see the square
wave has a peak there.
It has a valley there.
So the sine wave approximation
is going to have a peak there
and a valley there.
We're going to approximate
it as a cosine wave
of the same period and
the same amplitude.
Now, we might say, OK, that's
not a very good approximation.
What could we add to it to
make a better approximation?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE:
Another cosine wave,
which is what we're going
to do in just a second.
Because apparently
there's more I
wanted to tell you about this.
So we're going to approximate
this as a cosine wave that has
a coefficient in front of it.
We have to approximate
this is a cosine that
has some amplitude a1, and
it has some frequency, f0.
So a cosine wave
with a frequency f0
is this-- cosine 2 pi f0 T,
where f0 is 1 over the period.
And you can also write--
so f0 is the
oscillation frequency.
It's cycles per second.
There is an important quantity
called the angular frequency,
which is just 2 pi times
f0, or 2 pi over T.
And the reason is because if we
write this as cosine omega-0 T,
then this thing
just gives us 2 pi
change in the phase over
this interval T, which
means that the cosine
comes back to where it was.
So if we want to make
a better approximation,
we can add more sine
waves or cosine waves.
And it turns out that we can
approximate any periodic signal
by adding more cosine
waves that are multiples
of this frequency, omega-0.
Why is that?
Why can we get away
with just adding
more cosines that are integer
multiples of this frequency,
omega-0?
Any idea?
Why is it not
important to consider
1.5 times omega-0, or 2.7?
AUDIENCE: Does it have something
to do with [INAUDIBLE]??
MICHALE FEE: It's close,
but too complicated.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
sum just over the period
of their natural wave, right?
So if you add
non-integer [INAUDIBLE],,
you lose that [INAUDIBLE].
MICHALE FEE: Right.
This signal that
we're trying to model
is periodic, with
frequency omega-0.
And any integer
multiple of omega-0
is also periodic at
frequency omega-0.
So notice that this signal
that's cosine 2 omega-0
is still periodic
over this interval, t.
Does that make sense?
So any integer multiple
cosine integer omega 0
is also periodic
with period T. OK?
And those are the
only frequencies that
are periodic with period T.
So we can restrict ourselves to
including only frequencies that
are integer
multiples of omega-0,
because those are the only
frequencies that are also
periodic with period T.
We can write down-- we can
approximate this square wave
as a sum of cosine of
different frequencies.
And the frequencies
that we consider
are just the integer
multiples of omega-0.
Any questions about that?
That's almost like
the crux of it.
There's just some
more math to do.
So here's why this works.
So here's the square wave
we're trying to approximate.
We can approximate that
square wave as a cosine.
And then there's
the approximation.
Now, if we add a component
that's some constant times
cosine 3 omega-0, you can see
that those two peaks there kind
of square out those round
edges of that cosine.
And you can see it starts
looking a little bit
more square.
And if you add constant
times cosine 5 omega-T,
it gets even more square.
And you keep adding
more of these things
until it almost looks
just like a square wave.
Here's another function.
We're going to approximate
a bunch of pulses
that have a period of 1 by
adding up a bunch of cosines.
So here's the first
approximation--
cosine, omega-0.
So there's your
first approximation
to this train of pulses.
Now we add to that
a constant times
cosine 2 omega-T. See that
peak gets a little sharper.
Add a constant times
cosine 3 omega-T.
And you keep adding
more and more terms,
and it gets sharper and
sharper, and looks more
like a bunch of pulses.
Why is that?
It's because all of
those different cosines
add up consecutively
right here at 0.
And so those things all add up.
And this peak stays, because
the peak of those cosines
is always at 0.
Over here, though, right
next door, all of those,
you can see that that cosine
is canceling that one.
It's canceling that one.
Those two are canceling.
You can see all these peaks
here are canceling each other.
And so that goes to 0 in there.
Now of course all these cosines
are periodic with a period T.
So if you go one T
over, all of those peaks
add up again and
interfere constructively.
So that's it.
It's basically a way of
taking any periodic signal
and figuring out a bunch of
cosines such that the parts you
want to keep add
up constructively
and the parts that aren't
there in your signal
add up destructively.
And there's very simple
sort of mathematical tools--
basically it's a correlation--
to extract the coefficients
that go in front
of each one of these cosines.
And then one more thing--
we use cosines to model or to
approximate functions that are
symmetric around the original.
Because the cosine
function is symmetric.
Other functions
are anti-symmetric.
They'll look more
like a sine wave.
They'll be negative
here, and positive there.
And we use sines to model those.
And then the one
last trick we need
is we can model arbitrary
functions by combining
sines and cosines into
complex exponentials.
And we'll talk about
that next time.
And once we do that,
then you can basically
model not just periodic
signals, but arbitrary signals.
And then you're
all set to analyze
any kind of periodic signal
in arbitrary signals.
So it's a powerful way of
extracting periodic structure
from any signal.
So we'll continue
that next time.